magical creatures will feature  prominently and a number of them have  already been confirmed including  centaurs goblins grab horns moon cats  spiders trolls and hippogriffs the  official trailer even shows we'll be  able to ride hippogriffs cats and owls  are also shown in the trailer although  we don't know for sure about toads just  yet as for the more nefarious creatures  both inferior and dementors will make an  appearance and there's also this  enormous dragon if you look carefully at  the official wallpaper for the game  which you can download from the hogwarts  legacy website you'll be able to spot  floopers and an enormous acromantula  hidden in the forest